Okay, I need to hear your take on this one.
Buzzfeed News reports in a new interview,
the incredible Andrew Garfield.
He is like a walking jaw line.
He is goals, goals.
Well, he admitted he's, "Very uncomfortable", he said,
"when one of his friends makes a bad movie."
He says, "It doesn't happen often, but when it does,
"it's hard to know what to say
"'cause you run into them and you didn't love their movies."
And so what he says he tells them is,
"Well, you really did that."
Which I think it's so funny
'cause if you had a friend not maybe make a movie,
but do something that wasn't 100, what do you say?
I'm like, "Look at you."
Yeah, what do you do Rossi?
Well, I have a rule.
I call it, it's a short haircut or tattoo rule
where it's too late for me to do anything.
Like, my friend has a really short terrible haircut
or got a tattoo that's terrible,
there's nothing I can do to fix it so I just say,
"well, are you happy?
"Do you love it?"
(audience laugh)
But if you ask me first, "Should I get this haircut?
"Should I get this tattoo?"
I will give you the truth.
Smart, smart, Rossi, I like it.
Thank you, you can steal it.
(audience cheer and clap)
Short haircut, or tattoo.
Hey, we gotta talk about one of your favorites,
Jose Andres, this incredible Chef.
You all know who this is.
Well, his group, World Central Kitchen,
they've been doing amazing work on the ground in Ukraine,
feeding people since the very start of the war.
And now, "People" reports,
"Their sandwich line in Lviv
"is pumping out 10,000 sandwiches a day."
Think about that!
(audience cheer and clap)
Do the math, two slices of bread, that's 20 slices of bread.
And World Central Kitchen has served over 4 million meals
to Ukrainians so far.
And to support their incredible work,
we encourage you if you can, go to our website
for more information.
But we just wanted to shout out that amazing work
that Jose Andreas is doing.
Yeah, and I am going to make a $500,000 donation
to World Central Kitchen.
And I'm hoping that if somebody can help me match it,
that we can raise a million dollars.
Oh my God, Drew!
(audience cheer and clap)
Wow, wow, $500,000, Drew!
Yep, go to our website
I am in awe of what he's doing
and please let's raise money
because he is working in Ukraine,
but he is working everywhere.
He is front and center.
He does not waste time.
He shows up.
I wanna do everything I can to support him.
Wow, Drew that's so.
(audience cheer and clap)
Now, go to our website.
A dollar, anything, it will all make a difference.
(upbeat music)